spätabends in brandenburg vergangene
woche unweit der tesla baustelle liegt
ein wohnheim wir haben einen tipp
bekommen
hier sollen die arbeiter wohnen die auf
der tesla baustelle beschäftigt sind wir
drehen mit versteckter kamera
wo arbeitet ihr bei tesla auf der
baustelle
wir kommen aus der nähe von warschau
unsere beine tun weh wir haben heute 14
stunden auf sand gearbeitet dieser
verdammte sand wie viele menschen wohnen
hier
ich würde sagen um die 350 mann
geschlafen da teilweise mit bis zu drei
männern im zimmer wir werden morgens mit
bussen abgeholt und wieder zurück
gebracht und dann erzählen sie uns noch
etwas ganz anderes etwas überraschendes
welche arbeiten erledigen sie dann auf
der baustelle
wir verlegen da gerade abwasserrohre
dreieinhalb bis vier meter tief im boden
wir sind hier schon seit etwas mehr als
drei monaten tätig mittlerweile sind wir
schon so weit dass wir zahlreiche
baugruppen zu schütten sollen jetzt
straßen drüber gelegt werden
die arbeiter sagen die rohre sollen
schon seit mehreren monaten verlegt
worden sein doch die behörden behaupten
inzwischen die schachtarbeiten hätten
nur drei bis vier tage gedauert
mitarbeitern des landesumweltamtes
fielen bei einem kontrollgang diese
arbeiten auf daraufhin verhängte die
behörde zunächst einen zweiwöchigen
teilbaustopp erst vor zwei wochen hatte
das landesumweltamt eine vorläufige
genehmigung für das verlegen der rohre
erteilt außerdem prüft die behörde nun
ob sie gegen tesla ein bußgeld verfahren
einleitet bauen ohne genehmigung wir
fragen nach bei tesla
doch der konzern reagiert nicht auf
unsere anfrage inzwischen haben
umweltverbände aus brandenburg anwälte
eingeschaltet die sollen in ihrem
auftrag alle genehmigungen prüfen für
den bau der tesla fabrik
wenn hier ohne die erforderlichen
genehmigungen schon vorab heimlich
gebaut wird dann sagt das über ein
unternehmen das es hier mit den
gepflogenheiten in europa wie man sich
an gesetz und recht fehlt und wie man
die verfahren erst ordentlich bewältigt
und dann alles baut wenn es genehmigt
wird nicht so vertraut ist
ja also das zerstört eine
vertrauensbasis die ich jedenfalls von
der ich annahmen dass sie da ist
zumindest zwischen der
genehmigungsbehörde und tester dass man
sich sozusagen auf gegenwärtige zusagen
auch verlassen kann
das funktioniert natürlich dann nicht
durch eine partei bewusst über sogar
über bindende rechts regeln hinwegsetzt
also ich schockiert mich erst bauen
dann von den behörden genehmigen lassen
schon einmal agierte tesla so 2020 für
die statik der fabrik müssen fehle in
den märkischen sand boden gerammt werden
das ist in einem trinkwasserschutzgebiet
eigentlich verboten ohne erlaubnis der
behörden führte tesla zunächst test
rahmungen durch wir fragten damals den
brandenburgischen wirtschaftsminister
jörg steinbach nach den illegalen
rahmungen also wie der berliner sagt es
war einfach doof ja so und ich glaube
tesla hat seine lektion gelernt weil wir
haben die inklusive mir selbst am
telefon so was von maß genommen an der
stelle war glatt haben wir versuchen
hier alles stimmungsmäßig für euch und
dann baut ihr hier so ein mist und es
war auch ganz klar da passiert erstmal
nichts bevor wir das sich an der stelle
geheilt haben und die werden auch ihre
strafe zahlen müssen
und ich glaube sie haben ihre lektionen
gelernt lektion gelernt jedenfalls hat
das landesumweltamt bei der baustellen
überwachung eine menge zu tun
das belegen interne sitzungsprotokolle
aus dem umweltministerium
die überwachungsstelle stehe unter
starkem druck
eine andere abteilung fordert dringend
mehrere gespräche mit tesla notwendig
und das gegenseitige verständnis fehlt
kommunikationsprobleme müssen behoben
werden
tesla chef elon musk im vergangenen
sommer auf der baustelle voller
zuversicht
[Gelächter]
doch deutschland rock nicht wie geplant
eine endgültige baugenehmigung steht
noch immer aus in einem brief vor
wenigen wochen kritisiert er die
behörden und politik für das aus seiner
sicht langsame genehmigungsverfahren
tesla brandenburg schlägt daher
respektvoll vor dass die bundesrepublik
deutschland die grundlegenden änderungen
an den einschlägigen genehmigungs und
raumordnung sowie planungs gesetzen und
verfahren unverzüglich vornimmt um die
schnellstmögliche realisierung von
nachhaltigen projekten zu gewährleisten
nachhaltiges projekt damit meint ihre
maske vor allem seine giga factory in
grünheide die forderung mehr tempo zu
machen scheint er zum eigenen vorteil
bedacht
dabei sind die behörden aus sicht der
anwälte ohnehin schon an juristische
grenzen gegangen
bei diesen brief bin ich ihn wirklich
fassungsloses staunen verfallen weil
gerade der fall tesla hat auch zeigt
dass man im zuge dieses interesses nun
tesla hier anzusiedeln in grünheide doch
wirklich gerade alles möglich macht und
sogar mehr möglich macht ist das was das
europäische recht und zwar in ganz
europa als anforderungen hier fest
schreibt
doch nicht nur das abwasser ist ein
problem sondern auch das wasser zu
beginn der produktion braucht tesla für
den bau der autos bis zu 1,4 millionen
kubikmeter pro jahr so viel wie eine
stadt mit 40.000 einwohnern musk hatte
mit einem tweet im vergangenen jahr noch
beschwichtigt
ich glaube wir müssen ein paar sachen
klarstellen tesla wird nicht jeden tag
so viel wasser brauchen möglicherweise
gibt es mal einen selten in
spitzenverbrauch aber das wird kein
alltägliches ereignis sein
tatsächlich wurden jetzt schon zu hohen
wassermengen genehmigt jedenfalls aus
sicht mehrerer brandenburger
umweltschützer
sie wollen deshalb das
genehmigungsverfahren für die
wasserentnahme juristisch prüfen lassen
diese 1,4 millionen durch erlaubnisse
und bewilligung zustande gekommen die
wir jetzt wo wir gegen widersprochen
weil es da rechtliche und fans
rechtliche unklarheiten gibt es
erhebliche und eben unterlagen nicht
herausgegeben werden die umwelt
auswirkungen nicht genau beachtet werden
man keine informationen bekommt deswegen
muss man sich auf dem juristischen weg
hilfe suchen wir fragen nach beim
brandenburger umweltministerium das
teilt lediglich mit dass die erhöhten
fördermengen gemäß dem
wasserhaushaltsgesetz mit
wasserrechtlichen bewilligung zugelassen
wurden
brandenburg muss tesla wasser liefern
für die nächsten ausbaustufen benötigt
tesla bis zu 3,6 millionen kubikmeter
wasser umweltminister axel vogel
verweist auf ein mögliches
trinkwasservorkommen im nahen
hangelsberg aber reicht hangelsberg
reicht nach unseren erkenntnissen auch
für die ausbauschritte von tesla aus für
uns ist das thema wasser momentan
erledigt das problem handels berg ist
noch gar nicht erkundet es ist noch gar
nicht klar wie viel wasser dort zur
verfügung steht
bis zu fünf jahre kann es dauern dass
dort überhaupt wasser für die fabrik
gefördert werden kann
ich bewundere die poliker politiker für
diesen mut das so zu sagen weil man das
rechtskonformen wirklichkeit so nicht
sagen kann und ich kann verstehen dass
nachdem ein bundesland so vorgeprescht
ist und sich so engagiert hat diese
standort ansiedlung dorthin zu ziehen
und auch versucht alle folgen
durch solche versprechungen möglichst
einhalten zu können der sache nach aber
wird das so nicht möglich sein
nach wie vor ist unklar wann es für
tesla eine abschließende genehmigung
gibt für den fall dass sie nicht erteilt
wird hat tesla 100 millionen euro
hinterlegt für einen rückbau
[Musik]